hey friends design systems are essential
for creating beautiful professional and
consistent websites in this lesson i'll
show you the basics of design systems
and how they can help you as a new web
designer i'm going to break down what
design systems are why they are so
important and popular with web designers
right now and how they can help you as a
new web designer
[Music]
knowing which fonts colors and styling
will work best with your content and
brand is essential when you standardize
these things it's called a design system
design systems help you maintain
consistency so you're not making random
color and font choices at every turn
they're also beneficial when working
with more than one designer because
everyone will be following the same
rubric and set of design instructions if
you will headings are always this font
size buttons are this color corners are
rounded at 32 pixels and so on
design systems are critical when working
with a team or building a large project
they help maintain consistency across
all design elements which can be really
helpful when multiple people are working
on the same project design systems can
also help speed up the process by
providing a set of guidelines that
everyone can follow that said do you
always need a design system for every
single project
not every project needs a design system
in fact for small projects or one-off
landing pages they can be more of a
hindrance than help
in these cases you can probably skip the
design system and go with your gut
instead
all right let's talk about how to create
your first design system step one audit
your design
before creating a design system it's
helpful to audit your current design or
wireframe this means taking a look at
all of the user interface elements and
layouts structure that you're using and
noting what works well and what doesn't
you might also want to consider what
fonts sizes colors and design styles
work best for your brand this will give
you a good starting point for building
your design system now when you're
auditing your design make sure to pay
attention to the following font types
and sizes
color palette layout grid system design
style is it minimalistic modern
brutalist so on and so forth step two
create a consistent design
language a design language is made up of
a few key pieces typography sizing color
and graphics when you standardize these
key pieces designing your websites and
applications will be so much easier more
professional and consistent
especially as your project grows in size
over time
typography is a huge part of design and
when it comes to the web there are a few
key things to keep in mind
one of the best things you can do for
your web design is to keep your font
choices
simple
when you have too many fonts it becomes
difficult to create a cohesive design
and the text becomes harder to read plus
too many fonts can also slow down your
website's loading time simplifying your
font choices will make it easier to
design around a single typeface and make
your website look way more professional
so when starting a new project try to
stick with two or three different fonts
at most this will help you create a more
polished design overall
so where do you find great fonts
well there are a few great places you
can find free fonts my go-to is google
fonts they have a huge library of fonts
to choose from and they're all free to
use another great option is font
squirrel they have a good selection of
fonts and offer some commercial licenses
as well now if you want to keep things
really simple i recommend using system
fonts system fonts are a collection of
fonts that come pre-installed on most
computers they're typically simple easy
to read and make a great option for your
websites ariel helvetica times new roman
tahoma these are the most common system
fonts they load quickly you don't have
to think about font choices people know
these fonts and expect them to be decent
it's a great choice check out
systemfontstack.com for more information
on using system fonts in your websites
now here's a fun one the inter typeface
inter is a carefully designed typeface
developed by rasmus anderson and it's
probably my favorite sans serif font for
user interfaces it's available for free
on google fonts or from
rsms.me slash enter
if you have an adobe creative cloud
subscription you can also use the adobe
typekit library to add even more fonts
to your collection not available in free
font libraries the typekit library has a
vast selection of professional fonts and
they're all licensed for commercial use
a word of caution just because you have
many font choices to choose from that
does not mean it's a good idea to choose
many too many font choices can be
overwhelming and they can make your
design look cluttered it's always best
to stick with a few well chosen fonts
and use them consistently throughout
your design
when it comes to sizing and spacing
consistency is key this means using the
same font size line height margin
padding all throughout your design this
will keep a more polished look and make
your design easier to experience you
might also want to consider using a grid
system to help with sizing and spacing
a well-established color palette is an
integral part of any design system it
ensures that all elements of your design
are cohesive and look great plus it can
help make your website or application
easier to use by providing a visual
reference for users when choosing colors
for your design try to stick to a few
fundamental principles use a limited
number of colors three to five use
different shades and tints of the same
color to create variety stick to a light
dark contrast for easy readability and
use complementary colors for maximum
impact
now if you need help choosing colors for
your design there's a few great tools
out there to help you get started adobe
color creative cloud is a web-based free
web-based tool that allows you to create
custom color palettes you can choose
from pre-selected ones various color
models and you can also create your own
colormind is a free online tool that
generates color palettes based on an
image all you need to do is enter an
image url and colormind will generate a
palette of colors based on the image
coolors is a great free online tool as
well it's my go-to
it provides resources of what makes good
color palettes you can choose trending
popular and appealing color palettes
they have a whole bunch that you can
kind of choose from and it's a great way
to see what kind of colors you might
want to play with choose primary colors
base color palettes off of that color
lots of fun stuff you could do with
coolers another great way to get started
with picking a color palette is to draw
color palette inspiration from your
favorite brands check out their website
or social media pages and look at their
color palette try to mimic their colors
in your design or use use them as a
starting point for creating your own
color palette
graphics and icons are a great way to
add visual interest to your design but
when using them be sure to keep things
really simple too many graphics can make
your design look cluttered and when
selecting graphics and icons try to
stick with a limited number of styles
and shapes this will help you maintain a
cohesive design throughout your website
or application step 3 create a design
library in figma a design library is a
great way to keep your design elements
colors and typography organized and
consistent when creating a library be
sure to include all of the following
fonts colors shapes graphics and icons
and anything else you might need this
will make designing your websites and
applications way easier using a cohesive
style that you can draw from figma makes
creating a design library very easy
allowing you to create global styles
components typography sizing and more so
that your designs are more consistent
another cool thing about figma is when
you update or change something in your
global design library it will reflect
everywhere else in your design step 4
document as you go as you work on your
design system it's important to document
and update any changes you make this
will help keep your project consistent
even as your design and brand changes
over time
okay so we've looked at the essentials
of creating a design system for web
designers we've discussed the importance
of consistency and how to create a
design language using typography sizing
colors and graphics and we also looked
at how to build a design library and why
it's essential to document changes as
you go by no means was this a
comprehensive deep dive into design
systems but this should be enough to get
you started and to help you improve your
design skills and workflow along the way
i'll see in the next one
you